welcome to this video playing a get nice
89 let's see us laugh I played many
queen bee three is lady I try this again
results were quite ok I would say yeah
be sure a 5-iron i think is still the
main line maybe but i always thought
that this should be quite ok white as
always this is a position that in which
i actually would prefer white a bit now
there are two two main setups that white
can choose from i can play with with
rook t1 III Queenie to this kind of idea
helping that long-term my bishop on g2
will be better oh this is some something
entirely different normally you don't go
to d6 in this position because it runs
into e45 ok let's let's see Knight c3
rookie one this is the the second
possible setup and this I think gain
some some strength here now with the
bishop on g6
at least I don't have much to think
about here only have point square for
the Queen now maybe you can try with 94
playing it done playing it like that
okay seem seem and once to prevent
Bishop g5 yeah rookie one is normal and
then probably 94 otherwise eform look
some very inconvenient and I can
theoretically speaking could go pee
should be seven back and then II for all
the way back wed okay this looks this
looks better really so um night h4 I
guess attacking only form and attacking
on f 50 after 93 I can actually take a
five which is which is very nice he
cannot play the desperado on only two
and he must do that which is of course
strategically speaking quite quite quite
a problem a4 a5 on right very nice
position can also think of c4 c4 c5
let's maybe even better
see 524 Bishop is three so I go I go
this first just grab here it's no no
reason not to I can I can now trade down
with Bishop g5 and Bishop a form maybe
this is the simplest yep come on let's
do that and don't don't do anything
fancy just trade off to this end game
you have a tick now even has to take
with the Queen yeah now we have a double
rook endgame with the protected extra
pawn on c5 and it should be a relatively
easy win let's see support the opponent
I need the king of course without it
this won't work so let's go let's
activate the king check better push it
back it takes King f3 is made next move
so we must must retreat the king so how
to win this may be the one rook to a3
and to a 6 this is a good active active
rook position he has a 7 as a target
group a 66 is an additional point
winning the pawn here on you know I can
take a seven where I can also do it with
this check this rook
black resigns yeah oh that that that
he's doing that whoops yeah well bishop
d6 is a critical critical problem
because now it always runs into this
idea and it gets a bit bit tricky for
for black he probably should do this I
think this is the normal move and then
if we look for something similar then 94
is a different thing there is also this
this idea known i th form his on this
night this is a difference in the game
we had a very problematic position
because now our Knight c3 must he must
play and now I can do this intermediate
move he cannot desperado here because
this is a pin on the e-file so there's
really no move I fig if he moves the the
night back there is a four maybe not g7
also 97 h five so we we had we had this
position and now a for c4 is just very
good he probably should try c5 but it's
not it's probably beyond beyond saving
already and this is just technically
clean I think now taking the B file and
slowly and improving things check king
over and he couldn't take mid next move
so here what is just far too active and
wins the endgame rather easily alright
thanks for watching